foreign
[Music]
Tunisia is today a popular tourist
destination in North Africa it's a
country that has beautiful sandy beaches
incredible architecture delicious
Cuisine and a lot of culture to explore
and get immersed in but what many people
don't realize or aren't aware of is the
strong mystical history of this place
particularly its relationship with
Sufism
[Music]
thank you
the country has a long history as an
important cultural center of course in
ancient times it was the location of
Carthage one of the most significant
cities of the ancient world that also
had a very famous beef with the Romans
but later in history under the Islamic
hit Empires it continued to play a major
role the City of Cairo Wan is sometimes
considered the fourth holiest city in
Sunni Islam due to its prominence as a
cultural and religious Center in the
early centuries housing one of the
oldest mosques in the world
and the current capital of Tunis in the
north of the country has also hosted
some of the most significant Scholars
and Mystics in history
when you walk the modern streets of
Tunis today it can be hard to imagine
the Deep mystical roots that hide
beneath your feet and all around you
but once you know where to look they're
actually pretty easy to find
in the so-called Medina The Old City
District lies the great zetuna mosque
another one of the oldest in the entire
world originally built around the year
731 but with most of the current
structure dating from the mid 9th
century zaituna has always been at the
center of Social and religious life in
Tunis
here all the great Scholars that visited
the city would have come to pray and
sometimes also to teach people like IBN
Arabi Abu Hassan
khaldoon and everyone that we will talk
about today visited and worshiped in
this beautiful structure the minaret of
which Towers over the busy streets
in a way Tunis is a city of Saints and
only a few minutes walk from zetuna
mosque we find the azawia of Sidi mahrez
now zawia is the word commonly used in
the maghrebin western North Africa to
refer to a house or institution
associated with a Sufi order it's a
place where sufis will gather to pray
together recite litanese and to do
communal vicar azawia is often built in
association with the grave site or
Mausoleum of a saint which is important
to that order and sometimes the word
zawia simply refers to a mausoleum in
that sense without necessarily
connections to a Sufi order and this is
the case here
Sadie mahres was an important scholar
and figure in the early history of
Islamic Tunisia
he was a great scholar of the Maliki
School of Law and became considered a
Wali which is what we sometimes
problematically translate as Saint here
Wally literally means something like
friend of God and is given to people
considered to have had a special
spiritual status
is often considered the patron saint of
the city of Tunis and his Mausoleum is
an absolutely beautiful and peaceful
place which people regularly visit to be
in the presence of his Baraka or
spiritual Grace
wasn't necessarily associated with
Sufism per se even though he would
become important to later sufis in the
region but his Mausoleum is definitely
one of the most ornate and impressive in
the country due to his great importance
but as Sufism and its more developed
form started to flourish in the
following centuries Tunis and its
surrounding regions became a meeting
point for some of the most celebrated
Mystics in history
perhaps the greatest expounder of Sufi
metaphysics and history the Sheikh al-
Akbar or greatest Master
IBN Arabi visited the city on two
occasions indeed it was here that one of
his principled spiritual teachers
resided Abdul Aziz
stayed with him and his group of
disciples twice once in 1194 when he was
29 years old a stay which lasted for
over a year and another time in 1201
just before he permanently left for the
Eastern Islamic lands it was in Tunis
and under the discipleship of al-mahdawi
that IBN Arabi had some of his most
significant spiritual visions and
experiences
it is for example here that he entered
what he calls God's vast Earth or the
Earth of reality signifying one of the
highest stations on the spiritual path
indeed IBN Arabic consideredawi to be so
important and dear to him that he
dedicated his massive magnum opus
the meccan revelations to this great
master
Abdel azizawi is a significant figure in
himself even putting aside his role as a
teacher to IBN Arabi
he was one of the Central and most
revered Sufi teachers in the region at
the time having a kind of school of
disciples in Tunis he himself had been a
student of the North African Sufi
abomadyan which in itself gave him great
status
some might even have considered him the
kutub the spiritual pole of his age and
in general he was held in great esteem
he was as mentioned a teacher of the
great IBN Arabi but also of the more
controversial Ahmad al-buni author of
the original
but aside from accounts by these
students we don't know all that much
about his actual life
given the fact that both IBN Arabi and
albuni are strongly preoccupied with the
mystical powers of the Arabic alphabet
we might speculate that we might be the
connecting link here thus himself being
involved in that kind of Science in some
way but this is just that speculation
nonetheless this great Wali died in 1221
and was buried in the town of La Marsa
just a few kilometers outside of central
Tunas and bite by the Mediterranean
Coast his humble Mausoleum still stands
here today with a beautiful view of the
Mediterranean Sea I did visit the site
while I was there but it was a really
beautiful moment with the caretaker of
the zawia so it felt kind of
inappropriate to get my camera out I did
get these pictures of the surrounding
Cemetery though
also right by the Mediterranean coast
and not far from La Marsa is the
picturesque town of sidibusaid a very
popular tourist destination and
rightfully so due to its incredible
location and beautiful architecture but
even here while you are navigating the
tourist traps there is a central
undercurrent of religious and mystical
history
right
away
[Applause]
[Music]
I am currently in the beautiful little
town of sidibusaid in Northern Tunisia
just a few kilometers outside of the
capital Tunis this is a very popular
tourist destination it's very famous for
its blue and white architecture as you
can see here behind me many many
tourists come here every year but what a
lot of people don't know is that the
city or town has a very strong
connection to Sufism or Islamic
mysticism the town is named after a Sufi
Saint from the 13th century called
abusaid al-baji who would come up to
this mountain on which this town is
located called Jebel al-manar which
means the the Mountain of Fire basically
to meditate and pray for long periods of
time and then go down to the capital
Tunis to the zetuna mark to teach
because it was also of course a
spiritual teacher it is said that he
also built a kind of Fortress here so
they could keep out for any enemies or
armies that were approaching Tunis and
thus could warn the population in time
during his lifetime was a very respected
Sufi master of spiritual Master
associated with people like Abdul Aziz
who was a teacher also of IBN Arabi it's
quite likely that Abu said also himself
met IBN alabi and associated with him at
some point so he was a very significant
figure at his time after he died in the
mid 13th century a mausoleum azawia as
it's called here was built which you can
see right behind me the zawa is still a
place of kind of pilgrimage for many
Muslims around the world who especially
in Tunisia who come here to seek the
Baraka or spiritual Grace of the old
master
[Music]
oh
I've been told that sufis of the shadowy
order still gather weekly at the zawiya
for hadra which literally means
gathering in Arabic a gathering where
rituals like zikr or remembrance is
performed involving communal recitations
of God's names or phrases
for long periods of time that's a kind
of meditation you could say the zawia is
literally in the middle of the Town
among tourist-filled streets you can
easily miss it but the town is literally
built on its mystical Sufi history and
around the zawiya of Sidi Abu Saeed
al-baji
as you walk the main street of see the
bus side you will probably encounter a
cute Cafe reached by a flight of stairs
this is
literally the high Cafe it sits right at
the base of the zawia and in fact used
to be the old entrance from male
worshipers
inside the cafe you'll find a very
traditional looking room where they
serve some delicious mint tea and even
this place has a connection to Sufism
Not only was it previously one of the
main entrances to the zawia above but
according to the travel publication
sacred footsteps it has also long served
as a Gathering Place for Sufi
practitioners particularly in the
evenings after a long hadra session
walking down the stairs from the zawaya
after doing zikr for several hours the
male sufis would proceed to the cafe
continue to recite the prayers and
eventually have some very strong Arabic
coffee well deserved if you ask me
quite amazing to imagine when you sit
here drinking your tea or coffee that
Within These Walls so many prayers have
been sung and stories have been told and
in general to walk the streets of
sidibusaid among the crowds of fellow
tourists it can be hard to see past the
modern coat of paint but the great
Mystic that the town is named after Abu
Sayed al-baji remains a constant
presence here
he too was a student of the famous Abu
madyan in the west and became one of the
great Mystics of his age especially in
this region
he chose this mountain as a place where
he would go every day to meditate and
come close to God to find intimacy with
the reality that lies at the core of
existence and especially when you turn
away from the relatively modern
structures beautiful as they may be and
instead look out of the ocean and
mountains that surround you at those
natural features that have remained
unchanged and would have looked
basically exactly the same way to Abu
said as he sat here 800 years ago you
kind of understand why
[Music]
According to some stories I would say
that al-baji was also the teacher of one
of the most famous and important Sufi
Personalities in history but for that
story we'll have to return to tune his
proper because it is here close to the
city center of Tunis sitting on top of a
hill by the jealous Cemetery that we
find zawia belhasan
the name belhasan refers to Abu Hassan
the founder and Main figure of the
shadowy Sufi order and a Mystic who is
considered one of the greatest Saints in
Islamic history
Abu Hassan as shadowy was originally
from Morocco and became a Sufi there
under the discipleship of Abdul Salam
IBN mashish but it wasn't until he moved
to Tunisia but he started his career as
a spiritual teacher and Sheikh himself
indeed the name a shadowy comes from a
village outside of Tunis called shadila
where he recited for a period
eventually though he moved to Tunis
itself and started teaching there
building his first community of Sufi
students regularly he would Retreat to a
small cave on top of the hill in the
city to meditate and pray in the
darkness for long periods of time at
other times emerging to guide his
students on the spiritual path to God
eventually a shadowy left Tunis and
settled in Egypt where he established
his tariqba proper he is buried in
homeifara in Egypt where he died while
on pilgrimage to Mecca the Sufi tarika
or order that he started or was formed
around him and his teachings known as
the shadelia quickly became one of the
largest and most prominent in the world
a position that it retains to this day
particularly in North Africa the
shadelia is unquestionably the most
widespread and popular Sufi order and in
Tunisia his disciples continue to grow
and teach twin is had after all been one
of the main centers where a shadowy
spent his time
shortly thereafter azawia was built for
the shadowy order in Tunis however this
zawa was not built on the resting place
of the master as is usually the case his
Mausoleum was in Egypt after all Instead
This zawia was established right on top
of the cave where he would famously go
to meditate
this became the zawia belhasan or the
zawa of Abu Hassan which Remains the
main center for the shadowy order in
Tunisia
it's still active today as shadowy
murids will gather here every Saturday
morning for hadra where they recite the
litanese of the order and perform
intense zikr together
foreign
[Music]
you'll know that it is a very powerful
experience
the purpose of zikr is right in the name
remembrance to remember God and come
closer to God it's a kind of meditation
you could say where one focuses all of
one's Consciousness on the Divine
reality and thus purifies oneself of
egoism and self
the ultimate goal of zikr is to reach an
ecstatic State for the self to be
annihilated completely in God to realize
God's all-encompassing reality and
become United with him although this
uniting is a complicated concept and can
be very easily misinterpreted once a
week the izawia of Abul Hassan is filled
with the ecstatic mystical chanting of
the shadowy sufis a haunting call of
divine longing in words that date back
hundreds of years
the place is filled with the presence
one of the great Mystics in history and
in different ways not least because his
Cave of meditation lies directly under
the building a cave that can still be
visited today murids will go into the
cave into the very place where a shadowy
would have sat to pray and meditate
themselves an incredibly special and
Powerful experience that connects them
spiritually to the great founder of the
shadowy order
the statue of a shadowy looms over the
whole city
it's incredible to think that all the
figures we have talked about today with
the exception of CD mahres lived and
mingled here basically at the same time
in the 13th century what a place it must
have been
and we're not even done yet because one
of our shadowy students in Tunis was a
woman who would become incredibly famous
and revered in her own right and is
still an important figure in the region
her name was Aisha al-manubia but is
affectionately referred to as Saida
manobia
she was from the region of manuba which
today is basically a part of the city of
Tunis and was born into a prominent
family her father being an important
religious Authority in some way
eventually she chose to go her own way
and travel to Tunis proper to study the
religious Sciences of which she became
very proficient
a turning point came when she met and
became a student of Abu Hassan a shadowy
as he was established himself as a
spiritual teacher in the city in fact
she became one of the leading
authorities especially as Ashanti left
for the east
putting aside her role as a shadowy
student Saida manobia became a revered
and significant personality and Mystic
in her own right
as a woman she was quite unique in her
position as a spiritual and religious
leader for both fellow women and for men
it wasn't uncommon for women to be
spiritual teachers at this time even to
men as we can see from many accounts by
people like the aforementioned even
Arabi so the common idea that she was
completely unique in this regard isn't
entirely Justified
still this was certainly not the norm
and in this way Saida manubia was of
course very special as she broke some of
the gender assumptions at the time
she would engage in debates with male
Scholars and in general became a great
Authority
now for this reason said has become a
powerful symbol for women to this day
representing these spiritual and
intellectual power that women have had
in history and still have today
some even consider her a kind of
feminist icon for her breaking of social
norms although this should be somewhat
nuanced as we have said
she was an accomplished Mystic who
reached the heights of spiritual
experience and journeying which was also
reflected outwardly
Saida was known as an incredibly caring
and compassionate person spending much
of her time giving to the poor and needy
and taking care of those humans and
animals that were less fortunate in this
way she represented the importance to
the principles of love
a love that is directed primarily
towards God but which for that reason is
also extended to a caring love for
fellow creatures as not only creations
of God but as Reflections and
manifestations of God's being and
attributes
the zawia or Mausoleum of Saida manubia
stands in manuba the place where she
grew up and is still active today
it's become an important place for women
in particular who will gather there
regularly to seek her blessings and to
perform zikr chanting ecstatically
playing percussion instruments and
Performing ritual dance as a form of
worship of God which is common in some
Sufi circles but it isn't exclusively
for women of course as men will often
come here too even though they are often
separated during the rituals themselves
in general Saida manubia and herzawia is
a place of Grace for many people a safe
space not only for women but for other
groups of people shunned by Society in
different ways
the compassion and caring nature of
cider thus lives on in her place of rest
where people from all walks of life come
to worship God in a welcoming
environment
as we visited the zawia we were greeted
by the caretaker there who was an
incredibly kind and welcoming woman that
gladly answered questions and offered us
gifts something in the kindness of her
eyes and conduct reflected the character
of Saida manubia the tomb of whom she
was the caretaker as did the peaceful
nature of the place itself
it can be a wonderful experience to walk
the streets of Tunis the markets of the
Medina to smell the spices and the
incense it's an exciting modern city
that has a lot to offer in different
ways but hiding beneath the layers of
modernity lies a history of mysticism
and Sufism great Saints and Mystics
whose lives and teachings have shaped
not only Tunisia itself but the whole
world and actually not just a history of
Sufism but a living and thriving
tradition still practiced today that
stretches back into the distant past an
undercurrent of divine love ecstatic
longing and spirituality that has woven
the threads on which even a modern city
like Tunis rests
uh
foreign
[Music]